Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson is very concerned
about a floating space vagina.
That is not a headline that I would have guessed.
Two days ago I was going to be giving you
today.
This is the epitome of everything is scary.
I'm going to explain right wing fear mongering
to you with a segment in which Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson is afraid of a Turkish floating
space vagina.
What am I talking about?
Okay, here's the deal.
In Turkey, there was a cloud.
Okay.
The cloud to some people looked like a vagina.
And some of you will say, Well, David, really,
it's a vulva.
The vagina is inside.
We all know what I'm talking about, okay?
We're using the colloquial term that is usually
used.
Please, OB-GYNs, don't write to me about this.
It was really not like a huge deal.
It's just a cloud.
I mean, quite literally, it's a cloud.
But Tucker has to fearmonger.
So he does a segment saying this is really
a problem.
This is not normal.
Take a look at this.
We have seen pictures of the very strangely
shaped object that appeared in the skies over
Turkey.
Yeah.
What is that exactly?
It's not normal no matter what they tell you.
Plus, tomorrow, millions of churchgoing Christians
in America still vote for the Democrat.
Yeah, that he was moving on to his next scary
story that there are Christians who vote for
Democrats.
Maybe blame the vaccine would be a take away.
All right.
So, listen, this is it's so stupid, but this
is very, very instructive.
And I'll explain to you why.
Whether it's about big things or small things,
the right relies on fear mongering tactics
to gain support and to push their agenda forward.
If there is a specific person to blame.
Even better, if there's a particular group
to blame.
Absolutely fantastic.
It's a strategy that fear creates a sense
of urgency.
We need to know what to do now.
We need to know who is subjecting us to this.
And on and on and on.
The space vagina.
He's using the same rhetoric he uses with
a lot of this other stuff.
I don't know that he's necessarily suggesting
an investigation.
He just seems confused by it, I guess, in
some sense.
But the way that this works is you use the
fear to create the sense of urgency and to
otherize someone else, to agitate people,
to scare them, to say, well, tell me what
to do, please.
You've scared me.
Now what is it that I'm supposed to do?
And that's the point.
You use the fear to get people to take action
without fully considering the consequences.
And this is why right wing politicians will
often use fear to try to push for quick and
drastic changes to policies or laws.
Guys, we don't have time to sit and think
about this and to debate it.
There is a floating space vagina in Turkey.
We've got to do something about it right now.
Now, usually it's not a floating space vagina.
It's immigrants or communism that doesn't
exist or Marxism that they don't understand
that isn't Marxism or whatever the case may
be.
But that's how you slip changes through quickly
that aren't actually in the best interests
of the majority of people.
Fear can also be used to create division and
distraction from actual issues.
A floating space vagina is not a real issue.
Tucker's one hour show, once you take commercials
away, is probably 38 minutes or 42, if it's
like, you know, most corporate media shows
and every one of those minutes is going to
something rather than something else.
And when you do the space vagina thing, you
don't talk about an actual issue that affects
people.
And lastly, the fear is used to create an
us versus them mentality.
Now, he didn't go in this direction, but the
Turkish floating space vagina could be used
to make the audience suspicious of what is
it that turkey is doing?
What is Turkey up to exactly?
Well, they have a floating penis soon, or
whatever the case may be.
And it's part of this distraction method and
it fuels all of these other techniques that
I talked about.
So it's such a silly example.
It's a small example.
Although the cloud is quite large.
It's a small example, small scale example
of how everything leads to the exact same
rhetoric and tone.
And that's another fascinating and sort of
funny thing, whether Tucker is talking about
a potential nuclear war or a floating space
vagina, his tone is exactly the same, which
signals to people who have this stuff spoon
fed to them on Fox News.
They should be reacting with equal amounts
of fear to both of the things.
So it's quite sophisticated propaganda and
it would be better if people were more prepared
to defend themselves against it.